so the vision is the Malay Vision it's a
winning vision and we have to instill
this in our institutions because if we
do that then we can crush the ever
growing government and you may I think
we've shown this one twice but it's
worth it it's just beautiful this was
Javier malle's first plan of action
which he is now putting into place he
has already cut uh he had there were 21
government departments he's already cut
them down to nine but this was him
laying out exactly what he was going to
do
a lot of Spanish there for those
listening on the audio podcast but the
end was the thievery of politics is over
and he's just ripping off the titles of
these departments and he's saying no
more we will not fund them anymore we
will not take money from our citizens
for these ridiculous things like gender
and sports programs etc
etc